President Trump is defending his son for
meeting a Russian lawyer hoping to get
damaging information on Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump jr. has been widely
criticized after he released emails
showing how an acquaintance set up the
meeting last year he says it produced
nothing president Trump told the Reuters
news agency quote I think many people
would have held that meeting and he said
he didn't know about it until just a few
days ago
USA TODAY's Washington bureau chief
Susan page is with us she is covering
her sixth presidential administration
good morning good morning you heard the
president say in that interview with
Reuters that many people would have
taken such a meeting but with the
campaign manager with the president's
family involved does that ring true to
you
no I've covered ten presidential
campaigns opposition research is part of
all of them to be clear there is always
an effort by a candidate to find out the
most negative information they can about
the other side but to do so with an
agent of a foreign government and a
hostile foreign government I don't know
that that's ever happened before I'm not
aware of that happening before and for
it to involve the most the most senior
circles of the campaign that is also
really unusual so this is not the
political norm can you talk about the
match nations inside the White House
right now there was the category five
hurricane was one of the expressions
used if the president is trying to
potentially wall himself off from some
of these conversations that complicates
his work and his agenda that's right and
you know the one way in which it's
different from a category five hurricane
is that hurricanes come and go away this
is here to stay for some time because we
not only had this watershed event of the
release of Donald Trump Jr's emails this
week we've had two subsequent stories
that raised very provocative questions
on entirely different fronts a Wall
Street Journal story that says that as
of 2015 intelligence agencies were
hearing about Trump associates contacts
with Russians and I McClatchy story that
says there are signs that there may have
been coordination between the Trump
campaign digital operation and Russian
interests so this is like threads that
continue to get pulled and this is a
story a hurricane that isn't going away
any time the Ponzi story specifically
talks about Kushner that's right because
he oversaw that digital operation and
course one reason to particularly watch
Jared Kushner in these stories also a
figure in the Donald Trump email stories
because he attended that meeting is that
he's actually a senior White House
adviser he's someone who was working at
the White House now that raises some
additional quest so many questions about
his security clearance a member of the
Senate Intelligence Committee said
yesterday he knew about these emails and
that the committee knew about these
emails from the Russians back in April
how concerned is the White House that
there are more shoes to drop though we
don't know yet yes well the president
said in his interview with Reuters
yesterday indicating that this is
continued called it a hoax I think
that's hard to do in the wake of these
emails and that he hopes the worst is
over
I think he's told some associates and I
think there is no sign that the worst is
over and there are certainly more shoo
stirred up you know wouldn't we assume
they're more shoes to drop because it is
a complicated story with a lot of
different trails to follow and one thing
we know from special counsel
investigations is that they go where
they go and sometimes they go places you
never would have expected them to go
that's certainly an experience that
President Clinton had when he was in
office that's right the Special Counsel
Bob Muller now has six team attorneys on
his team helping with the investigation
let's turn now to the agenda that
Republicans had promised to carry out
for the American people repeal of
Obamacare tax reform first the health
care bill are there any closer with this
new bill to repeal and replace well if
Mitch McConnell gets a bill through the
Senate he deserves a Nobel Peace Prize
because there is such a divide between
conservatives who say this bill does not
go far enough to repeal the Affordable
Care Act and from more moderate
Republicans who are very concerned
particularly about the deep cuts in
Medicaid spending so it is hard to
imagine how he gets a bill through the
Senate but I think his calculation is
even if they lose they need to show
voters who if they have promised for
seven years to repeal and replace
Obamacare that they tried to do so then
they can move on to other issues but you
know health care is not going to go away
because there are big problems as the
Republicans have pointed out with people
particularly who participate in these
Obamacare exchanges so Congress will
have to come back to this but I think
Mitch McConnell calculates they need to
get this off their plate if they're
going to deal with raising the debt
limit with funding the government with
cutting taxes with anything else yeah
Susan page always great to have you here
and thank you for completing the primary
color we have them all here at the table
thing we're like a flag that's right